I don't know what twilight zone I'm
living in anymore so this really odd
news story broke about the upcoming film
the predator and it's writer director
Shane Black and another actor who was in
the film and I don't I have no reason to
talk about this other than it's so weird
I kind of want to talk about it and also
because it's like at least for me it's
it's like it's almost like a weird
follow-up to what happened with James
Gunn but you know it's
I have significantly different feelings
about it and then we'll kind of what
kind of get there so I'm gonna start as
bare-bones and factual as I can before I
get into my own feelings about this so
it was revealed that there was a scene
that was cut from the predator at the
insistence of Fox the studio releasing
it after having been contacted by Olivia
Munn who is one of the stars of the film
because it was a scene that she was in
so it's not it wasn't being cut for
content
it wasn't being cut to secure a certain
rating nothing like that it was being
cut um it's not I'm not gonna say that
Olivia Munn like asked that this be
taken out but she brought concerns and
the studio then removed the scene so
what the scene was well you know I'll
say what it wasn't a second the reason
that Olivia Munn had objections it was a
scene basically of her and one other
character and it was a scene that was
not particularly plot relevant it was
like a fun flavor kind of scene which
you know Shane Black has those and
they're usually pretty good so it was a
scene with her and another actor and
what she did not know at the time she
filmed it and what so far as I can tell
basically nobody except Shane black knew
was that the actor who
shared the scene with a guy whose credit
credited on IMDB as stephen wilder
although I think his legal name is
Steven Wilder strike oh I don't know if
he ever gets credited it is that in any
case he apparently is a sex offender a
registered sex offender who did time for
attempting to coerce a fourteen-year-old
girl into sexual activity over the
Internet so she raised her concerns
about having shared a scene with someone
like this would help being made aware of
what was going on and Fox
I mean Fox is not put out an official
statement on this I don't think but it
basically just looks like they looked at
this situation went yeah the scene isn't
vital we don't have to reshoot anything
we don't have to cover for just get rid
of it we do we don't there's a bad thing
just get rid of it so here's here's
where things get weird and weirder
because on the surface what this is is a
case of because this is an actor who's
been in shame black movies for a while
and Shane Black has known him for a long
time like 14 years they're more so
they've been friends for a long time and
black has put him in movies before he's
had similar scenes like one scene bit
part roles in Iron Man 3 in the nice
guys so on the surface what this appears
to be is Shane black basically doing a
favor for his friend helping him to
continue to get work and and the people
that he put him in to proximity with
were not comfortable with this person
now based off those facts I would
normally be pretty conflicted because I
do feel that people get at times
excessively penalized especially if it's
something they've actually served time
for it's it you know I do think we make
it overly difficult a lot of times both
societally and socially for people to
ever basically build their lives again
and
I don't want to get into an argument
about whether or not certain people
should be allowed to build their lives
again or what have you I don't really
want to open that can of worms but like
I I can get an argument you know I can
be torn on that kind of issue because
it's like okay what this guy did and is
history but you know this for whatever
reason I don't know I don't know this
guy I don't know Shane Black Shane Black
said well this guy's my friend I want to
try and help him continue to do what he
loves and I enjoy working with him and
there's a part of me that based off that
cenar that synopsis I just gave you
would go okay it's a little iffy that he
didn't let people know what they were
getting into working with this guy but I
get that he wants to help his friend and
you know that he was concerned his
friend was never gonna work again where
it loses me and where I end up coming
distinctly against Shane black and this
entire situation which is the inverse of
what happened with me and James Gunn and
again I would sort of come back and make
that comparison so here's why because
once you add the additional context back
in this whole thing is at best
massive misjudgment and just poor
decision-making on Shane Black's part so
firstly who this guy was sharing scene
with Olivia Munn is not just any actress
she's an actress who's been at the
forefront of the me to movement she was
one of I think it was four or more women
who accused Brett Ratner of some of the
really skeevy stuff that he was that he
was called out for so she has so we're
dealing in a time when this kind of
history in specifically in this industry
is trying is trying to be cleansed
because historically people in this
industry well not people men in this end
I'm not saying that to be anti male like
the people who were protected in the
Hollywood system who were moms
they were men I'm sorry that's what the
case was so they were doing horrible
things in the system protected them we
are it's in the process of trying to
clear that out so this is a real bad
time and a real bad environment to be
kind of basically sneaking a sex
offender onto set with someone who is
very much actively involved in trying to
clean up the mess that guys like this
were allowed to get away with for so
long and because we're not done the
scene itself now I haven't seen it
because it was cut it probably won't be
on yo blu-ray or anything like that but
that we do have a description of the
scene what the scene was was this guy
played a jogger who kept hitting on
Olivia Munn and she like blew him off so
shame black cast and again I understand
he's probably his friend no he is his
friend he's basically said as much he
cast his friend who has a history as a
sex offender to share a scene opposite a
woman who took a massive risk to her own
career to call out a harasser of women
and in that scene had this guy hit on
her when she didn't want to be hit on
wow just wow the total deafness I mean I
mean honestly including the scene at all
is a little bit like I mean I she black
him right very funny stuff so maybe the
dialogue saved it on an objective level
but you know it's a potentially
tone-deaf scene as is you had those
circuses like what and now to compare
this a little bit with James Gunn who
basically lost an ongoing gig
because of stuff he did a long time ago
that the employers should have been
aware of and you know if that was a
whole mess and I basically sided with
James Gunn on that that I think and I do
still think that his being fired by
Disney was messed up now Shane black
isn't being fired the movies already
done movie comes out later this week for
when I'm planning to get this video up
I'm recording this several days before
it goes up so it's possible that new
things have happened i I can't I can't
wait longer and do this I I have to
shoot it now I've got pride this weekend
in Vermont prides in September because
we're weird so you know I I'm shooting
it now but it's uploading later so
hopefully no major new wrinkles have
happened but at the time of recording he
hasn't been you know what I like is that
they can't fire movies done but I think
that this has a this is potentially way
more damaging in the long term to Shane
black than what happened with James Gunn
cuz what happened with James Gunn only
cost him his current gig like basically
as soon as pretty much the world agreed
that Disney was in the wrong studios and
and networks and whatever were lining up
trying to book gun to to work with him
so God was not hurting for extra work
black I think that unless the predator
performs really well and I mean it's
tracking to perform decently but unless
it really blows with my expectations I
think he's gonna he's gonna be banished
back to the indie level you know back to
when he did stuff like Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang again I think he's gonna lose
serious studio support he's not gonna be
able to do things like the predator and
Iron Man 3 again for a long time and not
because of some sort of you you
protected a you know a sex offender and
social justice demands that we must
punish you know it's not that what he
did legitimately put the
film project in the studio at risk cuz
he brought on somebody knowing this
person's history knowing that that
history could be bad PR for the movie
for the studio and did not make anybody
aware that he was bringing this guy on
so just from a studio you know
management perspective he now becomes a
liability especially because now we we
look back and go he's had this guy on
multiple movies now so he's been doing
this repeatedly and not telling people
this guy's history so from the
perspective of the studios they're like
this guy's a liability with James Gunn
it was all just about image and the
image of things he had tweeted out
clashed with the image that Disney liked
to have so Disney did something really
stupid over six year old tweet I still
can't believe out dumb that was but
anyways this is something that was
ongoing and current and potentially
damaging not just to an image or a brand
but the project itself and pulling that
kind of move that is the kind of thing
that gets a director I think rightfully
sent into direct director jail and again
I don't want to I don't want to get over
leave like aggressively judgmental on
this cuz again I I suspect to a certain
degree that Shane blacks what he was
doing was blinded by the fact that from
his perspective I'm helping my friend
and he probably didn't take a step back
to fully appreciate what it was he was
actually doing that doesn't make it okay
that doesn't make it excusable and it
doesn't mean that studio should go oh
well that's fine give him on another 100
million dollar movie to do well no back
that would be really stupid for them to
do and this you know as someone who is a
fan of his work it's unpleasant it's not
as unpleasant as finding out that he
himself is is some kind of sex offender
that obviously would
way worse but this isn't good it's a bad
look and it's not helped by the
statements that he put out defending his
actions and I'm not gonna go into a ton
of detail on this because I started to
look into it but then I started to dig
up the specifics about this guy's
conviction and I'm sorry god I just
don't wanna I just don't want to read I
just I don't I don't have the stomach to
do the research on this not this time
so I'm not gonna go into a ton of detail
on this but what I will say is the
statement that black put out he included
not only you know a general support of
this guy which you know what was he
gonna he obviously did know so I mean
what else was he gonna say but then he
implied that this guy was somehow
railroaded or tricked into soliciting a
fourteen-year-old over the Internet for
an extended period of time
mmm like guys I I read a very little bit
about this guy's conviction and about
the the I don't know if it was text or
messenger or what but messages he was
sending to this fourteen-year-old and
know just a whole lot of no so I think
Shane Black has further made things
worse for him and that's that's gonna
convict him in the court of public
opinion and then you know the fact that
he did this and like I said potentially
damaging to the film studios are gonna
look at him with a very cautious eye and
I think if he gets hired at all it's
gonna be at a much lower budget than
he's been allowed to play with up to
this point because he's gonna be seen as
a risk now he's a talented risk but when
you have a talented risk you hire them
but you give them much smaller projects
you know that's that's why M night
Shyamalan wasn't allowed to keep making
things the size and scope of The Last
Airbender and after earth but he could
still get financing for stuff like the
visit and split so although I mean not
too
compare the the the reasons why M night
Shyamalan was a risk with Y shame by
iLike I don't need to compare them but
just in terms of determining that this
director is a risk but they can do good
work that's that's the only reason I
made that comparison and I think I'll
wrap it up there I do at this bad time
of recording we'll see how I feel after
I sleep on this for a little bit but at
time of recording I do still plan to see
the predator I wanted to see it I really
liked the last trailer and like I said I
like Shane Black's movies and I'm not I
know I'm not somebody who calls for a
boycott I'm not gonna try and dissuade
anyone from seeing it but you know I
think I do have to kind of sleep on it a
couple days and sort of get a sense of
myself
in terms of my own comfort level of do I
actually want to spend money on this
movie now and and like is that at this
why I I do intend to I think I will yeah
but I'm not gonna promise that I I need
to sleep on it so I don't know man I
think the only reason I felt the need to
talk about this was cuz it was because
of the James Gunn thing and again it's
almost like the inverse at least as far
as my feelings go on it but just like
when director things this bizarre
happened it's like yeah can we talk that
out for a minute because wow dude just
wow so Shane black and this removed
scene from the predator what are your
thoughts about it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it please be respectful not
only to me but to the other people
involved because I will remove comments
if you throw basically hateful or
violent speech at any of the people
involved including Shane black so don't
use that language because I'll remove
your comments so keep it respectful but
whatever your thoughts are in whatever
direction drop something down in the
comments
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff to do there's buttons for likes
and subscribes and a link to my patreon
on all sorts of other links down there
too if you feel like checking them out
go for it and remember you are the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]